Bienvenidos a mi presentación de Álgebra:
ecuación de una recta.
Y bueno, pues empecemos.
Lo que quiero saber es cuál es la ecuación de una recta, que pasa por los siguientes puntos,
por el punto 1, 2, y también me voy a tomar el punto 3, 4.
Y bueno, yo lo que quiero es la ecuación de la recta que pasa por estos 2 puntos.
Así que lo primero que hagamos es que grafiquemos estos dos puntos, para ver en dónde estamos.
Así que dibujemos aquí los dos ejes, el eje "x" y el eje "y"
y vamos a dibujar aquí sus escalas
tengo 1, 2, 3, 4, 5 para arriba
y 1, 2, 3, 4, 5 para la derecha, éste es
el eje "x", éste es el eje "y".
Y mi primer punto, es el punto 1, 2, ¡perfecto!
es justo este de aquí,
y el otro es el 3, 4 así que lo voy a poner
justo por aquí, aquí estamos en 4.
Y ahora, me voy a tomar una recta que pase
por estos dos puntos, así que déjame dibujarla.
Y justo lo que queremos nosotros
es la ecuación de esta recta,
pero lo que sabemos es que la forma de la ecuación de una recta es "y" es igual a "mx" más "b".
Donde "m" es la pendiente y donde "b" es la
intersección con el eje de las "y".
Así que "m" es la pendiente y "b" la intersección
con el eje de las "y" o la ordenada al origen...
la intersección con el eje "y".
Si yo quiero encontrar la ecuación de esta recta,
lo que necesito saber es cuál es su
pendiente y cual es su intersección con el eje de las "y".
Y bueno, lo podríamos hacer tal vez
de una manera gráfica,
pero para no perdernos y hacerlo de manera muy exacta, lo voy a hacer de una forma matemática.
Entonces, lo primero que necesitamos es la pendiente.
Y bueno, recuerda que la pendiente habíamos dicho que es lo mismo, que ascender entre avanzar...
entonces déjame ponerlo aquí...
ascender entre avanzar...
avanzar lo que ascendemos entre lo que avanzamos...
Es decir, lo que nos movemos hacia arriba
o hacia abajo, a comparación de lo que nos
movemos hacia la derecha o hacia la izquierda.
El ascender entre el avanzar o dicho de otra
manera, el cambio en "y" entre el cambio en "x".
Muy bien y para esto, lo que hay que hacer
primero es el cambio en "y" .
Y el cambio en "y", es cuánto nos movimos en estos dos puntos, es decir 4 menos 2...
4 menos 2 es el cambio en "y" porque son los dos valores que tengo de "y".
Y abajo nos va a quedar el cambio en "x", es decir, cuánto estamos cambiando en nuestro valores de "x".
Y para esto tengo dos valores de "x", 3 y
1, entonces me voy a tomar la diferencia de 3 menos 1.
Y bueno, 4 menos 2 es 2, 3 menos 1
es 2 y por lo tanto 2 entre 2 es 1.
Esto quiere decir que mi pendiente tiene el valor de 1,
mi pendiente vale 1.
Es decir, que por cada unidad que yo me
mueva hacia la derecha,
me voy a mover una misma unidad hacia arriba.
Y eso tiene todo el sentido del mundo y si
yo me muevo una unidad hacia la izquierda,
entonces me voy a mover una unidad hacia abajo.
Y aquí se nota luego luego,
si yo me muevo una unidad hacia la izquierda,
una unidad hacia abajo, ¡perfecto!
Ahora, una vez que ya tenemos la pendiente,
lo que nos hace falta saber es la intersección
con el eje de las "y" o la ordenada al origen.
Y para esto lo que voy a hacer es poner el dato que ya sé. Ya se que mi pendiente vale 1.
Y bueno, sustituyendo esa información me
queda que "y" es igual a 1 por "x" más b
o lo que es lo mismo, "y" es igual a "x" más "b".
Y ahora lo que necesito es encontrar la "b",
y ¿cómo encuentro la "b"?
Pues bueno, lo que voy a hacer es sustituir
uno de estos dos puntos, o éste o éste.
Y bueno, para hacer las cosas más fáciles,
pero es indistinto, voy a utilizar el punto 1.
El punto 1 me dice que cuando "x" vale 1, "y" vale 2,
entonces vamos a sustituirlo en
esta ecuación de la recta que tengo aquí,
"y" vale 2, "x" vale 1, cuando "x" vale 1,
"y" vale 2, más "b".
Y entonces, vamos a despejar a "b" para que
con esto obtengamos su valor,
entonces voy a restar 1 de ambos lados de la ecuación,
estos dos se van y me queda que "b" es igual
a 2 menos 1, lo cual es 1,
¡perfecto! "b" vale 1.
Y bueno, ya tengo a "m", ya tengo a "b", por
lo tanto ya tengo la ecuación de esta recta.
Esta recta tiene como ecuación "y" es igual
a 1 por "x", lo cual es "x", más "b",
pero "b" vale 1 y... ¡ya está!
Tenemos aquí la ecuación de la recta que pasa por dos puntos, y ya quedó, ¡perfecto!
Así que para repasar, mejor vamos a
hacer otro ejercicio.
Y me voy a tomar un ejercicio muy parecido,
me voy a tomar la recta que pasa por
los puntos -3, 5 y 2, -6.
Y yo lo que me quiero encontrar es la ecuación
de la recta que pasa por estos dos puntos,
así que, en primer lugar saquemos la pendiente.
La pendiente es igual al cambio en "y"
entre el cambio en "x",
es decir, me voy a tomar
la diferencia en los valores de "y",
-6 menos 5 entre 2 menos -3. ¡Ojo! ten muchos cuidado
con todos los valores de los signos.
Aquí está la clave, y me queda -6 menos
5 es -11 y abajo voy a tener 2 menos -3,
lo cual es menos por menos más,
me queda 2 más 3, lo cual es 5.
La pendiente de esta recta es -11/5.
¡Oye! y no te has preguntado
¿qué es lo que pasa si yo pongo los puntos al revés?
es decir, si primero me tomo el 5 y después el -6,
me quedaría 5 menos -6 entre, primero
éste, y me quedaría -3 menos 2...
- 3 menos 2 y ¿vamos a llegar a lo mismo?
pues vamosa ver, 5 más 6, porque recuerda que menos
por menos es más, me queda 11, y abajo -3
menos 2 es -5, 11 entre -5, lo cual es -11/5,
¡perfecto, llegamos a lo mismo!
Entonces lo que te quería decir,
no importa el orden en el que te tomes la diferencia
de los puntos, pues si lo haces con mucho cuidado,
vas a llegar a la misma pendiente.
Y bueno, yo sé que todas las ecuaciones de la recta se ven como "y"es igual a "mx" más "b",
entonces lo que necesitamos es "b".
Para sacar a "b", voy a sustituir a "m" en
esta ecuación.
Y me queda que "y"es igual a -11/5 por "x"
más "b", porque "m" vale -11/5.
Y bueno, ahora, para acabar este ejercicio
lo que necesito es "b" y para obtener a "b"
lo que voy a hacer es utilizar uno
de estos dos puntos
y sustituirlo en esta ecuación
que ya tengo de esta recta.
Y dice, cuándo "y" vale 5, "x" vale -3, entonces
me quedaría, 5 es igual a -11/5 por -3 más "b".
Y hay que despejar a "b".
De aquí voy a obtener que 5 es igual a,
menos por menos más, 11 por 3 es 33, 33/5 más "b".
Y ahora voy a restar 33/5 de ambos lados de
la ecuación, "b" es igual a 5 menos 33/5
y ya lo único que tengo que hacer, es esta
operación que tengo aquí en fracciones.
¿Y cuánto es esto? 5 por 5 es 25,
entonces me quedaría 25 menos 33 entre 5,
y 25 menos 33, es lo mismo que
-8 negativo, bueno, 33 menos 25 es 8
y si yo me tomo que este es más grande,
entonces me queda -8/5.
¡Perfecto! "b" vale -8/5, por lo tanto, ya
sé que la ecuación de la recta
que pasa por estos dos puntos, tiene la forma,
"y" es igual a la pendiente, que es -11/5
por "x" más "b", pero "b" vale -8/5.
¡Y ya está!
Ya tengo aquí la ecuación de esta recta
que pasa por los dos puntos
y entonces, hemos acabado.